Wow look at you can I just look at you
for a second Tom what's up man how you
doing good more importantly how are you
doing during this whole crisis I'm doing
pretty good I've had a lot of things
going on so I tried to UM you know be
smart but not fearful and actually moved
to Tampa and I'm down here now my
family's here you're renting Derek
Jeter's place until you find a place of
your own right no I'm gonna stay here
for a while you know cuz I had to find a
place on really short notice and he's
been a friend of mine so we just talked
and it all worked out because he's
living in Miami he owns part of the
baseball team there the thing I heard
about Jeter's place which is great he
got special permission to build super
high walls so no one can get to you I
got to figure the fans down there are
driving you up a wall I mean you know
literally so Jeter has super high walls
and no one can see right it's almost
like Osama bin Laden's compound not
quite that's a derrick did a pretty good
job of screen in it and I think I'm a
little bit of a introvert I feel like my
house is kind of the place where I can
relax in you know when you walk outside
the house you understand everything that
goes along with being me and right you
know and I think part of it is when I
come home I want to feel like I can you
know let my guard down and relax but
this is a little different cousin you
got to the backyard there's a lot of
boats that are pulled up and out behind
let's say the washing machine breaks
does Jeter have to come over and fix it
because you're paying I call and I [ __ ]
to him and get your fix everyone thinks
they want to own a home and it's nice to
rent I mean I would definitely say like
there's no you can get all the benefits
with none of the responsibility so I'm
totally cool with this yeah I mean how
does that all work like does Jeter like
say look Tom were your friend but now we
got to talk business this is what I'm
charging you a month and do you kind of
say hey you know dude what about a
little price break here or was it a
family yeah who negotiated that not
neither of us so other people handle it
so it worked out good he left it
furnished for me so I don't have to deal
with any of that so it's just a lot of
great things about it not uh not crappy
furniture in other words I know you're a
bit of an architectural freaky you love
to design your own home and you look at
Jeter's taste and you don't want to
throw up he's got great taste
did Jeter collect like a first month
security the
and then last month security deposit a
because you know you're like my lawyer
over here I mean he was pretty good
about it
so we handled it the right way he's he's
a really cool guy and I've known him for
a long time so I'd actually be was
pretty simple man over the years when
you were playing with New England and
everything and doing your thing there
were so many times you almost came on my
show well first of all I'd love the show
for a long time I lived in Boston for 24
about 15 years and I would have a about
a 30 40 minute drive into work every day
so I listened to you for years upon
years and and I always loved really a
lot a lot of things I mean your work
ethic in you know how important it was
to you how important you take your job
in how you prepare and you know the
collective teamwork of it so I always
thought you know if I ever win on the
show I'd want it to be really good you
know because I think you you just have a
way that that you know you make you make
things very special